bonjour daniel dalin merci d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui sur l'alternance alors
la situation était telle que ce nouveau
confinement était nécessaire selon vous
oui je pense que selon moi les autorités
ou une sage décision que deux dans un
premier temps d'installer un d'instaurer
un couvre-feu puisse appuyer a pas un
confinement
il faut pas oublier que la guadeloupe
avec son sang chu qui fonctionna à
moitié et ils n'ont normalement la côte
de la martinie s'entraîne
or la martinique elle aussi subi de
plein fouet le variant de variantes et à
la solide
on en est à 19 morts donc je pense que
lille ont pris la décision la plus sage
d'autant plus que normalement la marine
normalement lamartine et c'était une
ville qui aime tant sanitairement par
l'entente la guyane que la roue de l'eau
donc à sur ce point de vue je n'ai rien
à dire on est dans une autre résidence
et de 828 400 à 1000 habitants en ce
moment en guadeloupe quelle est la
situation dans les hôpitaux vous parliez
d'entr'aide entre la martinique et la et
la guadeloupe
à quelle situation des hôpitaux en
guadeloupe alors la seule chose à savoir
que l'hôpital de la guadeloupe a subi le
chu de guadeloupe a subi un incendie à
devient quelques années de ça il est le
système
l'hospitalisation est en pleine
réflexion
n'oublions pas que nous sommes sur des
îles ils écoutent où les capacités
sanitaires sont naturellement faire le
par rapport à ce qui se passe dans
l'hexagone et je pense que c'est par
souci de prévention on a préféré mettre
la guadeloupe sous cloche au moin la fé
pour la martinique et eux aussi à la
réunion pour éviter que le colloque est
plus de plus de décès n'oublions pas que
17% environ à peu près de 17% environ
des guadeloupéens et des martiniquais
seulement et ils sont sont vaccinés
alors vous avez peut-être déjà
entendu des réactions dans les rues de
guadeloupe
quels ont été les premières réactions
justement après l annonce de ce nouveau
confinement
alors bien sûr nous sommes le peuple
nous sommes le peuple fier un peu
rebelle il faut aussi ramener ça à
différents différents malentendu je
préfère dire malentendu entre guillemets
mais c'est un euphémisme malentendu
entre les décisions qui sont prises ici
en france hexagonale paris et avec des
répercussions sur le département
d'outre-mer je veux parler par exemple
de nous avons traversé des épidémies re
du cadet des infections de masse tels
que la chlordécone je pense que le
phénomène de la chlordécone joue aussi
pour beaucoup dans la défiance de notre
compatriote monica et martiniquais parce
que c'est un sujet qui a été mal pris
par moment dans l'impression que l'état
a tenté de le dissimuler
et ce qui fait que la population les
populations antillaises sont vent debout
contre toute décision que pour être en
état
mais soyons lucides il est important je
ne pense que ce soit maintenue parce que
c'est pas un martini pour le moment nous
sommes à 19 ans je pense que si on met
on sait pas ce pauvre ce c'est beaucoup
beaucoup plus de 2,2 de l'essec il va
vous parler de la défiance un instant
des guadeloupéens envers la vaccination
27 7% de la population guadeloupéenne a
reçu déjà eu une première dose vous
parliez d'épisodes comme le chlordécone
c'est tout ça hein qui et qui rend un
petit peu les décisions du gouvernement
pas très sûr pour les guadeloupéens
c'est ça ben je pense que lorsque vous
voyez que dans l'hexagone les médis si
j'en étais souvent contradictoires ce
qu'y avait-il dit la veille n'était plus
valable dans demeure bien ce qui avait
été dit avant le ministre à melty
contredit par un autre tout ça ça
rajoute à cette cacophonie et qui fait
que
nous on tienne comme nous voyons ça de
très loin on a l'impression que que
voilà ce petit paris il n'est pas un
départ en cash et de vérité au hall e ou
au premier ou au le bon moi je dis qu'il
faut que notre population antillaise se
fassent vacciner parce qu'elle avec
toutes les commodités existence dans
l'île
n'oublions pas que les problèmes de
tension des problèmes de proches des
problèmes de cancer de la prostate
ce qui fait que les gens sont son
interview les gens peuvent avoir un trou
de deux diminutions de digne l'autre
unité très faible tous ces problèmes là
font que nous sommes nous sommes nous
sommes obligés et je dis bien si tu as
un devoir de rappeler à nos compatriotes
faites vous vacciner si vous voulez au
moins au tgv aux anciens et la chine
merci beaucoup à daniel dalin d'avoir
été avec nous aujourd'hui sur arte
france rappelle que vous êtes président
du conseil représentatif des français
d'autres si vous permettez je veux
ajouter quelque chose je tairai son nom
il s'est permis le luxe de sortie mais
une connerie style c'est parce que nous
sommes un peuple inculte
j'aurais simplement rappeler à ce
médecin à ce sinistre médecins les
antilles ont donné et était une scène
exceptionnelle qu'elle paie mais césaire
et que glissant tels que je crois est
nommé la liste elle est née et que tenir
de tels propos du racisme du racisme
ordinaire et j'attendais aussi il rudoie
de dépenses contre on ne peut pas
laisser michon en tout cas le message
est passé merci daniel dalin je rappelle
que vous êtes président du conseil
représentatif donc à des français
d'outre-mer